enfin sont à participer à danse avec les
stars oui nabila telle excellente
danseuse
j'aimerais qu'on se fasse une petite
danse ou les de la photo
[Musique]
il sait pas
ce pas
[Musique]
mais
pensez déjà des marseillais et cette
polémique avec ses poissons dans le
jacuzzi regarde
[Musique]
ça
le crij alors ça ça énormément fait
réagir est ce que ça vous a choqué ou
pas sur le plateau alors énorme alors
derrière je voulais juste vous dire
cette séquence à fait normal pas fait et
non non et agir notamment l'eau silva
mais si c'est un poisson dans l'eau
chaude et jacuzzi des poids soirée
monsieur noah on les met dans l'eau oui
mais là ils ont alors ils sont pas morts
là vous dit d'aimer ce qui touche aux
animaux je suis jamais ne le défend
énormément la fondation bardot
[Rires]
on dit des animaux mais c'est des
crustacés
les poissons qui vit dans les ressources
et des crabes mais je défends 200000
habile à ce qui dit il ont même pas de
sens les voix centristes a tant donné
nabila ce soir c'est nabila couscous et
là ça devient un peu fatigant tout ce
qui se passe sur la toile je pense que
c'est très bien de prendre la parole à
ce moment là parce que c'était par
rapport au cinéma c'est des choses qui
se sont passées dans le cinéma
si elle a envie de le dire maintenant
c'est très bien et je pense que ça fait
déjà dit nabila rien c'est très bien
qu'elle le répète ça vient ajouter une
pierre à ce qui s'est passé parce que
ces mecs là c'est un vrai mais je sais
très bien que tout le monde le sache et
que ça se répondent comme ça c'est
encore mieux comme ça ne se reproduira
peut-être paul et tous les jours oui
d'accord avec géraldine je trouve que ce
n'était pas le moment c'est déjà un 63e
festival de cannes qui a été extrêmement
plombant elle n'a fait que répéter
plutôt plus mal ce qui avait été dit
pendant tout le festival
et franchement il ya un moment pour tous
et autant je comprends sa douleur au
temps là à ce moment là ça ne passait
pas à mon avis
je ne connaissais pas du tout et
l'exercice est arrivé comme ça il m'a
dit d'imiter donc avec naulleau qui est
un livreur
[Rires]
j'ai une question très importante a posé
un habile à parce que nabila je vous le
dis j'aimerais que tu reviennes dans tpm
pays mais c'est vrai j'aimerais beaucoup
que tu reviennes à cherry est ce que je
serai prête à revenir dans tpm paix à la
rentrée j'ai très envie que tu reviennes
oui franchement bon c'est vrai que
touche par ont passé une expérience que
je n'ai pas pu terminer que j'ai
vaguement goûter et donc
donc c'est un exercice qui me plaît j'ai
pas mal d'autres activités mais je pense
revenir
ouais
[Applaudissements]
merci la bulle arrivants